foreign
ship carrying weapons of mass
destruction these coast guards on a
mission to intercept the vessel a
helicopter ready to help in any search
and rescue operation
this is a scenario designed to train the
coast guards of the Philippines United
States and Japan together for the first
time that's the best way we can do the
interoperability and the training that
three nations agreed upon
the exercises are taking place on the
edge of the South China Sea about 25
kilometers from the coast of Bataan in
the northern Philippines but the
waterways claimed almost entirely by
China
four Coast Guard vessels are
participating in these exercises too
from the Philippines one from the United
States one from Japan but there is a
fifth one on the horizon that serves as
a lookout for any unwanted entity some
of those so-called entities could be
China flagged ships they've been
patrolling the South China Sea and
adjacent Waters with increasing numbers
and frequency
in April the crew of a Chinese Coast
Guard vessel was accused of trying to
block a Philippine Coast Guard boat
nearly causing a collision a similar
incident happened last week this time
between the U.S and Chinese navies in
the Taiwan Strait the fact that this was
announced over the radio prior to doing
it clearly indicated that was
intentional but China blames the U.S for
escalating tensions in the region I want
to emphasize that the truth is that the
U.S side stirred up troubles and made
provocation first while the Chinese side
dealt with this in accordance with
corresponding laws and regulations under
President Ferdinand Marcus Jr the
Philippines has forged closer security
ties with both the US and Japan the
first Maritime exercises between the
three countries are the latest sign of
an emerging Coalition that is seeking to
counter China's growing Regional
dominance
together are
promote a free and open indo-pacific the
Philippines U.S and Japan have planned
for months to carry out joint patrols
into south of China Sea
drills like these featuring Coast Guard
vessels from the three nations next to
each other in Open Sea showed that
future has arrived
one below Al Jazeera in the south of
China